on passe bien ça vient de sortir
aujourd'hui on a toutes les infos
personne n'en a parlé c'est exclusif
sorti à quelques heures il ya quelques
heures qu'est ce qu'on a sorti merci
closer et on les infos aussi avec magali
maître gims a décidé on l'a dit est ce
que tu veux devenir le nouveau jean
jacques goldman des [ __ ] il est dit
non je serai le maître gims des [ __ ]
je vais créer un contre-feu et une
nouvelle organisation pour les
associations encore plus grosse c'est
notre sujet de la semaine
jingle sortie dans closer donc lui que
je te l'est lalalalalala la paternité de
cette enchère et wii nommé maître gims
étaient contactées par le par tf1 pour
lui dire est ce que tu veux pas venir un
peu redynamiser les [ __ ] parce que
ça a un peu perdu et estimant car un
nouveau moteur ça peut amener un public
jeune et c'est lui a dit non mais moi je
vais pas venir aux [ __ ] c'est un peu
fini
moi je vais lancer par contre je veux
bien évidemment mettre mon célébrité au
service d'une cause
donc moi je veux bien qu'on fasse à une
nouvelle plus émission de charity de
charité et est donc on va appeler ça les
salles auparavent alors je pense que
c'est le projet parce que je voulais
salopards oui oui c'est en opposition
oui d'accord la troisième sera quoi les
reculs et voilà ce que je vois là je
trouve ça moi aussi un peu bizarre donc
savais que je pense que ce nom du projet
les salopards aussi mais bon ça
s'appelle comme ça pour le moment
presque c'est le cas et il va donc faire
ou une grosse émission avec des stars
contre je dis oui dont jennifer asics
fermé après son but d'amuser pas des
mots clés saisis de compléter quoi diva
mariah brufau c'est très bien que tu
seras team [ __ ] ses frères de dire
lui parce qu'il paraît que rossi date
jouer tous avaient l'air de dire que
maintenant y aura les jeunes et que les
cartes vermeil les les autres sauces
trop sur quel rezai 6 16e à 40o ya
sûrement pas lui qui vont la salle
florent pagny zazie et jennifer on
connaît ça sera là ça va être incroyable
un sacré coup dur pour les anciens c'est
très dur pour dieu et daniel attendait
mais on sait pas pour l'instant si c'est
en concurrence avec les restos du coeur
par commentaire c'est pas les [ __ ]
tresquois de telles oeuvres humanitaires
sont les restos du coeur les [ __ ]
c'est la soirée qui sert à financer bien
sûr que bien sûr il fait ça pour venir
en aide aux restaurants du coeur en
complément pour avoir un public
différent à spa c'est une superbe idée
évidemment maintenant si c'est en
concurrence des restos du coeur c'est
con
mathieu cissé en compte c'est au
contraire si ça en complément c'est pas
une super idée ils vont se tirer la
bourre
ils vont ce calibre on élit balisé il ya
une des sourds avec l'est sera moins
normaux et faire deux émissions
radicalement différent que ce serait pas
pour les restos du coeur me l'a dit en
tout cas je veux une nouvelle soirée je
ne veux pas aller aux [ __ ] chasse
avec ce qu'ils veulent ces gens alors
justin siegel ces gens c'est quand même
hallucinant
les [ __ ] on en a besoin il ya des
gens qui crèvent de faim france en 2019
ce spectacle-là permet à un car je crois
du budget des [ __ ] de donner à
manger à des gens qu est ce qu ont ces
gens ce moment ces artistes à cracher
dans la soupe et magali voilà il est
hors de question hors de question de
concurrencer les [ __ ] c'est autre
chose un autre projet c'est pour
d'autres causes ça n'a rien à voir donc
pour l'instant c'est tenu secret je peux
vous annoncer que ça sera certainement à
la rentrée ça va être annoncée voilà il
va y avoir une brouille stratégie
derrière nous c'est pour une belle cause
et franchement tout cause est bonne a
servi ou alors est donc franchement
c'est complémentaire mais en aucun cas
est vraiment personnellement je vous le
dis ce n'est pas du tout pour vous c'est
pas en opposition des [ __ ] jamais
voilà donc c'est au contraire une
nouvelle cible exactement et c'est hyper
loeb très bien si c'est dit comme ça
lorsqu'il s'est dit comme ça je ne
pensais pas qu'un jour on conclurait
cette émission avec magali berda avec
une phrase en français et des enfants